momento de hablar de economía aquí en
france24 me acompaña en el estudio
daniel hablando con daniela muy buenas
noches ya se empezaron a conocer algunos
datos preliminares del desempeño
económico en el 2020 hola santiago
buenas noches mire el dato que por lo
general se conoce más rápido siempre es
el de inflación y ya hay por lo menos
una decena de países que dieron a
conocer cómo les fue en 2020 en términos
generales una de las consecuencias de la
pandemia ha sido que los precios de la
canasta familiar han bajado ya que hay
un menor consumo por lo tanto pues bajan
también los precios no es el caso al
parecer de venezuela que sigue siendo el
país más inflacionario de la región
según la oposición sus precios
aumentaron en más de tres mil por ciento
el año pasado y argentina otro país con
graves problemas de inflación cerró 2020
con un acumulado del 36,1 por ciento
este es un resultado de santiago de
todas maneras mucho mejor si se tiene en
cuenta que en 2019 los precios tuvieron
un alza del 54 por ciento y había sido
la mayor desde 1991 otros países como
perú estados
2 bolivia registraron niveles bajos de
inflación y en colombia fue la más baja
de la historia daniela hablemos ahora de
los resultados de crecimiento económico
que ha tenido alemania que es el motor
económico de la unión europea sí señor
el producto interno bruto se contrajo un
5 por ciento en este país de según la
oficina de estadísticas esto significó
su mayor retroceso en 12 años desde la
crisis financiera muy recordada de 2008
y 2009 en ese momento se había contraído
un 57 por ciento los organismos
multilaterales no estaban tan errados
pero sí fueron un poquito más pesimistas
de la cuenta la osa de proyectaba por
ejemplo para este país una caída del 5.5
por ciento y el fondo monetario
internacional- estimaba que iba a ser
del 6% los sectores más perjudicados
fueron servicios comercio transporte y
hostelería por supuesto hablemos ahora
de eeuu daniela el presidente electo joe
biden anuncia un mega plan económico
para sacar a este país de la crisis mire
se trata de un paquete de estímulo por
uno
8 billones de dólares que pondría en
funcionamiento yo by the end una vez
llegué a la casa blanca y tenga la
aprobación desde luego del congreso que
es lo más difícil como ya sabemos el
paquete incluiría un billón de dólares
para ayudas directas de 2 mil dólares
por familia otros 415 mil millones de
dólares serían para reforzar la
respuesta a la pandemia y una cifra
similar ayudaría a las pequeñas empresas
en momentos en que el desempleo está
volviendo a subir y más de un millón de
personas pidió subsidios en la última
semana lo que no se veía desde agosto
escuchemos
una mayor respuesta fiscal o más
legislación proveniente de washington
sería útil para levantar la economía y
ayudar a los más de 19 millones de
estadounidenses que todavía reciben
algún tipo de asistencia por desempleo
baksi a medida que pasa este año que
administren vacunas y que las personas
puedan retomar algunos de sus hábitos de
consumo la economía comenzará a
recuperarse pero mientras tanto es
necesaria más ayuda
daniela ya no una polarizada nicaragua
comienza la negociación por el salario
mínimo para este país centroamericano
así de santiago el gobierno una parte
del sector privado y los sindicatos que
son sandinistas instalaron este jueves
la mesa negociadora para fijar el nuevo
salario mínimo de los trabajadores para
la vigencia de 2021 el promedio del
salario se mantiene congelado en 181
cinco dólares y los sindicatos están
proponiendo un aumento del 5 por ciento
con lo que quedaría en casi 195 dólares
pero los empresarios dicen que es muy
posible que no se llegue hasta ese nivel
debido a que la economía global se ha
venido contrayendo desde 2018 también la
de este país y sobre todo en 2020 por
culpa de la pandemia el 28 de febrero es
la fecha del límite para lograr un
acuerdo y el más reciente aumento fue
del 2 63 por ciento pasamos a ahorrar
los indicadores como las ffaa las bolsas
en la jornada los estímulos económicos
movieron a wall street a la baja
haciendo el standard and poor's o el que
más caro las principales bolsas europeas
subieron por el contrario pendientes
también de joe biden y en américa latina
hubo ganancias generalizadas y brasil
por las pérdidas del día anterior cifras
del día para el cierre los 3,9 millones
de euros en esa cifra se subastó en
parís un cuadro del recordado tintín que
estaba guardado desde antes de la
segunda guerra mundial
daniela muchas gracias gracias a ustedes
por las sintonías toda la economía sigan
france24
[Música]